the last thing i wanted to spend a few
minutes talking about today
uh was
uh prompted by my thinking about this
this piece i'm working on for tuesday
about gift giving and
uh it
it took me back to actually this this
lovely book human universals a 1990
human universals that was a 1991
in 1991 book by donald brown uh which
i'm going to read a couple of very short
excerpts from but we
we relied on it in part in
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century including
just to share
a little bit
um
including in these first two paragraphs
from the final chapter the fourth
frontier
humans make sense of the past so this is
these are things that all humans all
human cultures even if not all in human
individuals have been understood to do
humans make sense of the past and
imagine the future we have help in this
from our uncommonly large frontal lobes
and from one another
our children are exceptionally curious
and learned from adults and from one
another from the environment and from
experience we coalesce in large groups
multiple generations working and living
side by side we use language experience
menopause mourn our dead and have
rituals to mark events and seasons
we harness the productivity of earth sea
and sky for our own ends we domesticate
other organisms for food and textiles
labor and transport protection and
friendship
we tell stories both fact and fiction
we have unlocked many of the universe's
secrets substantially freeing ourselves
from the natural order that created us
but many of our strengths are also
cryptic weaknesses
our outsized brains are prone to
confusion and miswiring our children are
born helpless and they remain dependent
on us for an uncommonly long time
our great linguistic diversity severely
limits to whom we can talk
even our bipedal gait so important in
allowing us to move and carry things on
the ground comes with risk to mother and
baby and childbirth and reliably causes
back pain
we're gossipy sentimental and
superstitious we build extravagant
monuments to fictional gods we are
arrogant and confused often mistaking
the unlikely for the inevitable even as
we downplay massive and obvious hazards
in everything
trade-offs
so
he
i went looking in this book the human
universals book for um what i thought to
be true and what he he affirms is true
about the ubiquity of gift giving um
gift-giving traditions in various
uh in various forms across human
cultures and indeed he claims that there
is no there is no human culture in which
some form of um gift-giving is not
uh is not found
but there are a few other things in in
looking through this book that are are
notable i think about what humans
have what has been ubiquitous in human
cultures and which we should all be
thinking about remembering
around now
uh so he's talking about an imaginary
not imaginary the universal people the
up
which are the you know the people
who are all of our human ancestors
the universal people have law
at least in the sense of rules of
membership and perpetual social units
and in the sense of rights and
obligations attached to persons or other
statuses
among the ups laws are those that in
certain situations proscribe violence
and rape
their laws also proscribe murder
unjustified taking of human life
although they may justify taking lives
in some contexts
they have
sanctions for infractions and these
sanctions include removal of offenders
from the social unit whether by
expulsion incarceration ostracism or
execution they punish or otherwise
censure or condemn certain acts that
threaten the group or are alleged to do
so
so some of what we're seeing at the
moment is
those of us who disagree with the one
narrative that is acceptable are being
sanctioned
censored
ostracized
uh expelled from a decent society
in some cases incarcerated you could
argue um in in some places and
hopefully that doesn't continue to
spread um but you know the
the wisdom the ubiquitous human wisdom
of recognizing that laws of this sort
are necessary uh also mean that they are
of course gameable
it occurs to me that they are bringing
us in attempting to train us and when it
doesn't take they're sanctioning us
rather exactly like what
george bridges the erstwhile now
departing president of the evergreen
state college said he would do to those
who disagreed with the new orthodoxy yep
finally
the universal people know how to dance
and have music
at least some of their dance and at
least some of their religious activity
is accompanied by music they include
melody rhythm repetition redundancy and
variation in their music which is always
seen as an art a creation their music
includes vocals and the vocals include
words i.e a conjunction of music and
poetry
the up have children's music
the up particularly their youngsters
play and play fight their play besides
being fun provides training and skills
that will be useful in adulthood
we need to remember these things
we need more music we need more dance we
need more play
we need to remember that collective joy
is actually a fundamental part of what
it is to be human
and the fact that they were able that
that forces that sounded like they were
on our side were able to take away so
much of this and that in many places
including where we are living now they
are still gone
and people are just getting used to it
and now getting in the habit of
defending their more restricted lives
because they feel safer this way
the fact that some people feel safer in
a world that is authoritarian and
sensorious and ever narrower with the
blinders on your own on you on your own
particular lane does not mean it's the
right way to live nor
do you have the right to constrain
everyone else around you in this way
so i'm i'm struck by that description of
effectively the characteristics that we
infer that the ancestors of all our
modern cultures would have had
um
because the point is those effectively
are the human universals
we are watching them abandoned and
dismantled
what does it mean that they are being
abandoned and dismantled and why would
they ever be and one answer which i
think is
likely to be right
is that in effect
something has decided that it does not
have shared fate with the rest of us and
this happens this is what happened you
know in in weimar germany where uh one
group decided that it could dispense
with others
and i think the point is this is what
happens when something defects from the
agreement that unifies you and what we
are seeing now i am increasingly
convinced
are end game dynamics
people's people's heuristics for
understanding what's taking place
are not working because they're not used
to a civilization in which something
with a great deal of power suddenly
defects and it takes all of the
structures that had a meaning and it
starts co-opting them like medicine why
is my doctor suddenly not able to tell
me what my doctor thinks is in my
interest with respect to my health right
why is my doctor not allowed to tell my
pharmacist to give me a particular
medicine and in what way is that
therefore still in any real sense my
doctor right it's not something has uh
it's as if you know
it's invasion of the doctor snatchers or
something
um
and
this
i think people are going to have to
recognize that the first step to getting
out of this
is just recognizing that it is
unarguably happening
right and i think the problem is many
people
are constructed their development has
caused them to think that at the point
that you recognize
that something terrible is occurring
then the point is okay then what do we
do about it and the answer is we don't
actually know what we do about it
because this is new to all of us right
we actually have lots of analogies for
pieces of this but i think we are
lacking for example um a
a great
turnkey totalitarian novel that would
tell us what it would feel like if this
happened to us and so a lot of us are
missing it
but it is as we discussed a couple of
weeks ago
from the great
novel catch-22
better to live on your feet than to die
on your knees
a hundred percent so
first step
script yeah but um here we go
you gotta recognize that it's happening
and then once we get enough people to
recognize that it's happening then we
can talk about what we should do about
it
and to return to where i started today
um
my sense overhearing yet another
conversation in which people are
speaking
privately and saying well i see the
stuff that's happening but i know that
nobody else is
the fact that i keep landing in
situations where i'm hearing that sort
of thing tells me that
there are
many more of us than most think
and yeah we
we aren't in a great position to tell
from the fact that our inboxes are
overflowing and we don't respond to the
vast majority of people of you know of
good people with amazing stories that we
would love to be responding to because
we just get too much of it but you know
if you just went by that and you had
confirmation bias you would be certain
that it was everyone who was saying this
and it's certainly not it's obviously
not that um but the fact that i can
um
when i am just going out into the world
with the hope of uh you know having a
coffee and working on a podcast and um
hopefully being anonymous and able to
listen to conversations around me
repeatedly hearing this sort of thing
even in the
um
you know
still we're in mass mandate territory
portland oregon
suggests that there are a whole lot of
people who are
who are considering living on their feet
so let's do it yep
[Music]
all right start by admitting what you
suspect yeah and and uh acknowledging it
even if just in small ways with the
people with whom you're interacting
at the you know at the store with your
family with your friends uh pointing out
the inconsistencies that are the most
obvious first and uh then continuing to
expand the
the flaws in the arguments that we are
being told to believe in uh from there
the time for being timid is over i think
so
[Music]
you